I think there is a contradiction there
and what I worry about I think a lot of
us environmentalists worry about is in
this you know it feels very much like
being green living green has become this
incredible fat and all the you know the
good news is is that you know consumers
do have an enormous amount of power and
there's various ways to get corporations
to move in a different direction and one
certainly and one is certainly
regulations and forcement of laws and a
carbon tax and and so on but another way
is by consumers making a radical
expression of we want to do things
differently we want different kind of
products we want products that aren't
gonna pollute the environment and of
course that gets corporations to move to
so in a certain way you've seen the real
movement alone behalf of some of these
corporations but i think that the danger
is is if we decide that we can consume
just as much as we always have we just
have to consume products that have a
slightly less damaging impact on the
environment we're not going to get there
we really have to change kind of how we
live our lives and in a more significant
way than that and i think the part of
that is asking ourselves is my level of
consumerism really healthy for the
planet even if it doesn't admit quite as
much carbon and so on there's a certain
point at which we have to maybe not
consume some so so much now this can you
know the danger of what I'm about to say
is it can sound paternalistic but I
would argue that actually consuming less
is is is a recipe for happiness in this
country in a certain way because I think
that we first of all as Americans we run
around with our heads cut off we're also
stressed we work too hard we're running
thin if you will and and we we don't
take as much time as we should spend
time with our friends and with our
family to get out in nature and do
things that are spiritually fulfilling
and sustaining and I think that part of
it is that we're also kind of consumer
addicted we all were kind of looking for
the new X you know the new ipod or the
you know the new car whatever it is and
i think that that that tracks from our
connection to nature which i think it's
a really really important one
that really gives the grounds people I
know that when I go out and do a
backpacking trip with my friends and I
get way off in the desert in the
mountains and what have you I'm never
happier I never feel more at peace with
myself I I never feel kind of more
connected to the world around me that I
do in nature and I and I you know
hesitate to say I'm paternalistic but I
think that Americans frankly would find
a more fruitful path to happiness if we
could kind of back off on they kind of
heavy duty consumerism I think it kind
of gets in our in our way spiritually